hola
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no no
[Música]
entonces queremos cambiar al mundo pero
la pregunta es cómo cambiamos al mundo
cómo cambiamos esta realidad en la que
vivimos cómo cambiamos todos los
problemas que los humanos hemos creado
problemas de contaminación por problemas
sociales muertes de animales todo eso ha
sido causado por qué
por el egoísmo y por la avaricia de los
humanos
hace 20 años era muy distinto y
podríamos darnos cuenta de la gran
diferencia de hace 20 años
cuando las abuelitas iban al mercado
todo lo que compraban productos de
limpieza comida todo eso eran guardados
en
eran guardados en bolsas de tela también
algo que deberíamos volver a hacer es
utilizar las botellas de cristal que se
utilizaban cuando alguien tomaba leche o
tomaba refresco este es un claro ejemplo
de lo que sucede cuando empezamos a
utilizar el plástico esto simplemente
sucede en la escuela o también lo
podemos ver en la calle y a nosotros no
nos importa
hace mucho tiempo alexander von humboldt
nos dijo tienen que tener cuidado
nuestro planeta puede en algún momento
decaer
él fue de los primeros que nos avisó
sobre el cambio climático muchos lo
tomaron por loco
esta es una realidad en la que vivimos
muchos compartimos en nuestras historias
de instagram problemas ecológicos
muertes de animales todo eso
ante todo esto que yo vi en mis redes
sociales dije por qué no empezar a hacer
un cambio porque no empezar a hacer la
diferencia
hace tres años yo creé bolsas hechas a
base de materiales textiles un día dije
por qué no empezar a hacer la diferencia
empecé a hacer estas bolsas un día
agarré mis jeans viejos que ya nadie iba
a querer
están rotos no lengua a utilizar otra
vez agarro un agujero y empecé a hacer
estas mochilas también se preguntarán y
tú qué más hiciste empecé a dejar de
utilizar botellas de plástico empecé a
utilizar cantimploras para mi agua y si
por ejemplo en algún momento tenía que
comprar algo de plástico lorre utilizaba
otra cosa que empecé a dejar hacer
es empezar a reutilizar todo lo que
tenía o adornar toda la ropa que tenía
y bueno también dije porque no busca
otros proyectos en los que pueda ayudar
y eso hice encontré unos proyectos muy
inspiradores de los que también podemos
ayudar por ejemplo el proyecto de un
mexicano que creó unos tenis a base de
botellas de plástico y pues él empezó a
reutilizar como yo
me inspiré igual un proyecto en
australia que pusieron redes en cuando
desemboca al agua de ríos y mares y toda
esa basura que está en el agua la
recolectada en las redes para que así no
se siga contaminando y otro proyecto que
muchos vemos en nuestras redes sociales
es un proyecto sobre los artistas que
recolectan todos los toda la basura que
está en las playas en los mares todo eso
y empezaron a hacer pulseras de estos
materiales y obviamente todos queremos
donar para ayudar
un claro ejemplo
estas son varias historias de instagram
en las que muchos de nosotros y yo
compartimos todos los problemas y todos
esos que creen que están haciendo una
gran diferencia pues literalmente no lo
hacen muchos creen que la gente piensa
que no saben lo que está sucediendo en
nuestro planeta
pues tengo una noticia es las personas
que comparten sus historias de instagram
a todos estos problemas la gente sabe lo
que sucede porque no empezamos a dejar
de compartir en nuestras historias de
instrumenta todos los problemas que nos
que han causado a la humanidad y por qué
no empezamos a compartir nuestras
soluciones alguna idea que tú tengas
para ayudar a nuestro medio ambiente eso
es lo que debemos empezar a hacer
compartir soluciones
a todas esas personas que comparten sus
instalarán les hago una pregunta tú qué
vas a hacer tú qué vas a hacer fuera de
tu celular para ayudar al medio ambiente
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]